boy I used to mow some [__] Lawns
that was my my dad had me running a
shitty lawn mowing business when I was
like 11 me too I mowed lawn I had my own
lawn moo business from as far as fixing
[__] you can't like and stuff no I can
do that [__] yeah can you I'm not GI can
you can hang shelves and all thatu yeah
I don't think so oh shelves yeah yeah
yeah yeah TV yeah I hang on my own TVs
you piece of [__] my girl I I that car
there was a little thing hanging I go I
got to take it in the shop Danny goes
what I go that thing's off she goes it's
the plastic she gets on you just push it
push in TI on she like you're a [__]
like I just came from doing putting my
own tires and wheels on my truck oh okay
oh yeah that's right you're a truck yeah
I'm not a complete like this is me look
I don't know yeah I can't do any of that
[__] I don't even try at this point it's
like I got a lot of [__] to do that is
pretty profitable so I'm going to pay
some [__] like five bucks an
hour who knows how to put these shelves
on a lot better yeah but and my girl's
so used to me being completely useless
but then when it's something bike
related CU I spent like 20 years riding
bikes I snap into action and I can fix
the [__] fly Tire in like 5 minutes
and she's like this is so strange to see
you actually being capable of doing
something with your hands right yeah
you're Gearhead when it comes to bikes
right but nothing else yeah and a very
specific part cuz I rode BMX bikes they
don't have gears they don't have brakes
so those are the two things that are
like kind of complicated dealing with
bikes so everything I can't true a wheel
I can kind of tighten the spokes so like
all the stuff that's actually difficult
with a bike I can't do but all the easy
[__] how long did you ride BMX bikes for
for a long time 20 years yeah and you
were
good I was no no I was not like a pro or
anything like that I didn't I didn't
really have like much of a hey day but I
was all right I like kind of persever
you did it long enough to know you're
not a pro I was all right yeah it was
your passion though like it was your
like you were all in super into it yeah
super into it you know like there's some
dude at your [__] MMA gym or whatever
[__] you got going on where it's like he
loves it he's so into it he's watching
every fight he's so motivated into the
culture but also like there's no way
it's just not yeah it's never happen
yeah there's a lot of those guys nice
guy like to see him around the gym but
yeah he's never going to make a living
doing it yeah yeah and you knew that
when early on very early on yeah I was
like oh I'm definitely not Pro material
but also I didn't even know that was a
thing I didn't even see the path because
I like in New Hampshire the Pro BMX
world is in California and maybe a
little pockets of like Florida and New
York and [__] but in New Hampshire I
didn't even know anyone who was
sponsored at all so even having that you
know blueprint was totally foreign to me
then when when did you realize you could
make money and doing what you're doing
now not everything you're doing now but
like podcasting well because early I was
just on the internet from day one and
then at a certain point I look at at uh
you know in like 2006 I was like oh [__]
there's all these blogs emerging online
I could do this but for bike riding and
basically started this website that kind
of took over the BMX World very quickly
I did that for like 10 years and towards
the end of that time I had a bunch of
other [__] going where I like started a
bike shop in downtown LA I had a podcast
where I was interviewing all these pro
riders and Company owners and [__] like
that uh doing Vlogs all the time and
having a lot of success on YouTube and
everything but like kind of right as
that started to do well then I also was
just spending a lot of time going to
[__] uh underground rap shows and
[__] and then started interviewing those
dudes and all of a sudden that [__] just
exploded so far past the bike stuff that
I was kind of like all right this path
has been chosen for me I got to [__]
see how far I could take this [__] cuz
that's how I found you was the the
hip-hop stuff I had the BMX I had no I
had no idea and then I had a weird
experience the other day where I was at
this poker game and all the dudes are
talking to me about the porn [__] and
after a a couple hours I realized like
they probably don't even know that I
[__] interview rappers constantly cuz
the porn [__] is so it's overwhelm it's
hard to think about anything else when
there's some porn playing in the room
right but also 100% yeah but you're also
the only one doing it like you're the
guy yeah you know like there's nobody
else like oh Adam does it like this like
his porn well nobody's doing a podcast
where you have the a porn star on and
then you have sex with that only.com
yeah plug plug.com shout out to you guys
for mentioning that wife yeah like the
stars aligned for you to be the face of
this movement every guy's like this
every guy's like hey that sounds like a
really good
time I'll put it on tonight like you
believe this at a certain point we kind
of realize like oh all we got to do is
just push the limits and do more and
more risque [__] and the media will just
latch onto it and have to talk about it
so that's why we just did a game show
trying to find a guy to [__] my wife you
know they did like the bachelorette but
for porn and he funded himself shot
himself the winner gets to [__] his wife
we did it the other day it's available
now it's all small clip of it you and
the guy like fist bump all a lot of
people were pissed off about me fist
bumping a a small black man while we
were banging my wife together but oh
dude he's small big dick but short guy
Little D is actually his name oh Little
D but Big D this guy he's working with
the piece yeah yeah and that was your
idea just to start this kind of The
Bachelorette but that was actually kind
her idea she was just like well if we're
going to do a scene with another guy
together how can we draw as much
attention to it as possible oh she's
Savvy them business wise yeah she's
smart and she had like ran into this
company or this guy who basically like
puts high quality YouTube Productions
together and we just hired him and he
kind of helped us map the whole thing
out how long you have you been with her
and how'd you meet her 8 years or almost
8 years serious run dude and uh I met
her
because she DMD me and she was trying to
she was working for some social media
company and she wanted me to like
interview some random models that worked
that were being managed by the company
that she worked for and I right away was
like all right cool but you should let
me take you out to get some drinks or
some [__] and then we hung out and we
started seeing each other soon after 9
years you're you're both extreme
Personalities in some ways she's very uh
hospitable
uh like very she's like the nicest
person you ever meet which really stands
in stark contrast to me being a little
bit rough around the edges yeah you're a
nice guy too that's the thing reasonably
but you're an honest you're nice like
people are like I can't believe your
friends with that I'm like he's never
been mean to me you strike me as very
honest that's what that's what I think
is cool and I think even me and her
We've ran into a lot of problems where
I'm from the east coast is very normal
for someone to say to me like hey we
should go to this restaurant and me to
say uh I don't want to go that that
place is [__] disgusting you [__]
and like that that to me is just a
normal way to communicate and I used to
have that [__] problem when I was
living in Brooklyn I remember some girls
from Southern California came and hung
out with us for a couple days and at one
point they just said like I can't
believe you guys talk to each other like
this and you just direct yeah and and
and just rude but assuming that the
other person knows that I don't hate you
just cuz I called you a [__] idiot
it's all love yeah that is so East Coast
by the way that's so East Coast it's a
very cultural thing it's it's kind of
bros in general like the way you and I
talk to each other sometimes yeah well
we're not going to we're not going to
compliment even if we compliment each
other I'm then I have to end it with go
[__] yourself of some kind you know what
I mean like you know what I mean it's
just yeah it's a it's a thing like where
where we most guy language like guy Cod
yeah but the East Coast for sure like
especially you know out here it's more
of a culture of niceties on the East
Coast it's just like there's snow it
just sucks Philly there's a lot to be
upset about yes yes shoveled my mom's
car out today Massachusetts up there
when you're freezing New Hampshire
you're freezing your balls
off but with uh you were talking about
the the media pick up whatever you guys
do I think you're good at dealing with
like obviously you get a ton of
promotion people love it and they get a
ton of hate oh yeah and then it's like
like the whole narrative like oh this
cuck I'm like oh he's laughing all the
way to the bank though yeah like you
guys can say that sure and to each its
own like I don't give a [__] what you do
like you know what I'm saying like
that's your own personal
thing you want to do so I don't know why
people care but like oh this guy's a
cuck I'm like but you realize he's
laughing all the way to the bank while
doing this yeah also also you you're
making a relationship work for eight
years that's that's a an accomplishment
yeah I mean honestly I think a
connection you guys have us doing [__]
with other guys on camera I think it uh
if anything it kind of makes everything
feel a little bit more fair in our
relationship cuz we went all these years
where I probably [__] like 300 girls
with her at at over over the years on
camera and a handful off camera and you
know it's just it really doesn't matter
that much to us like I could totally
imagine her like the the difference is
though it's like all the guys that we
would ever potentially do content with
it's just they're they're porn guys you
we don't we think of them as like it's
like getting a plumber and you're doing
it together you're you're kind of going
on this adventure together and building
this thing together a guy he's doing the
job yeah and then he leaves and like but
people have a hard time wrapping their
head around it in their head it's got to
be a little bit romantic it's got to be
some real freaky [__] whereas in reality
you're getting together you're making a
piece of video content together kind of
like this a little less pressure I don't
have to get hard on or anything no we're
going to [__] we're going to [__] well
Brian's hard right now hard sh hard is a
rock great you're looking for if you
need Bri is making appearance on plug to
thinking about being a cuck yeah you
want a 56y I don't know if you want 56y
old hair that's hot it's a different
demo so yeah so your viewers can be
like blur that out but but how how do
you deal with like the obviously like in
the current climate like a lot of people
aren't acceptable to it but you guys
still do it so how do how do you deal
with like all the hate you get or like
people like I can't believe you let your
wife do that or when you look at your
ratings well the weird thing the past
few months only go so far but yeah but
the weird thing the past few months is
that it's like we kind of Hit the sweet
spot where we triggered the conservative
conservative media world and all of a
sudden I'm watching this guy's [__]
boss do videos about me with all his
little buddies laughing at him
St Crowder I was
watching never ack me I just do the show
okay what fair that is his boss I do the
show Once a while but don't act like I
don't know what's going on my buddy he's
my buddy his boss my boss I'm like hey
wait a minute is he doing is he doing
videos I've seen one clip of him talking
about me but it's like I don't you know
I mean it's just need magic M after that
it's great like I'm not upset about that
at all I think it's awesome like it's
just promotion like and to be fair
somebody like Crowder it's more like
haha look at this stupid thing that this
guy is doing it's not so much like this
is destroying the West American society
is crumbling because of this kind of
thing cuz a lot of people think that
we're on like a mission to basically
like you know ruin the American Family
unit whereas for us it's more like no
like I'm not suggesting that Brendan
shab's life would be better if he
brought some black man into his
relationship to [__] his wife like why
would you do that unless unless you had
a specific fetish where that was your
thing which to be fair is a lot more
common than I think like I don't I don't
really have that fetish or anything this
is just content for us but you know uh
it's not like something I'm trying to
like Institute in other people's lives
it's more just something that kind of
works for us as
Entertainer you're so direct it's so
good it's impossible to look bad when
you're honest the way you're so honest
about it's like you're just [__] and
I know cuz I know I have a shitload of
friends who are basically like hardcore
conservatives wellknown and not known
and like I mean I get along fine with
him and it's not like anybody like I'm
sure if I met Crowder that we would talk
for 10 minutes and he would be like oh
this guy he may be a disgusting cuck but
we we get along on everything else so
who gives a [__] you know so I don't
really stress it too much silly good
some people you'll fire back at like Joe
Buon was giving you some [__] right and
then you you lit up Joe Buon yeah I mean
Jo who it is he's just like a weirdly
like vengeful Petty type of person where
like I went on his podcast and basically
just like went to war with him and his
co-host and pretty much like destroyed
them and just like basically left them
looking like shells of their former
selves and then I felt like instead of
just accepting that L Joe Buton like
found all these like weird little
roundabout ways to kind of like diss me
and get at me and and I just had had a
lot of people in the hip-hop industry
tell me not to trust him and tell me
that he's basically a piece of [__] and
I kind of and I even like I I just I got
a bunch of warnings didn't go for it and
then as time went by it kind of proved
itself to me of like oh this guy is a
very good Entertainer but he's also
really a [__] he just seems like he
just seems salty yeah you know what I'm
saying like like when Drake said he's
like you guys are listening this guy who
never made it oh you don't know Joe
Buton okay oh okay I know yeah look at
this today T big podcaster though Adam
22 calls out Joe Buon for bashing his
marriage to under the plug look at look
how topical we are love it but again
that like that's how you cut through all
the noise right uh yeah I mean we got
TMZ on speed do we hit him up anytime we
got anything going on so that's how it
go I didn't tell him to talk about this
I just told him about the [__] uh the
scene this is Little D right there um
and Joe button's basically saying what
well he was saying that he thinks my
relationship is fake that the that we're
we're using an inappropriate definition
of the word wife he thinks the whole
thing is just for Content it's like bro
we have a kid together we're about to
have another kid not now but like
probably this year we're about to start
going for another kid uh I don't know
it's weird how people see something
that's slightly outside the realm of
possibility in their relationships and
decide that therefore this must all be a
work or judge it yeah like you have no
[__] clue yeah I think Joe A A lot of
people mess up too they think for
whatever reason because just tattoos on
your face that you're dumb like when you
said you lit up Joe Buton it's like yeah
yeah Adam a dumb dude they had me on the
show and they tried to use a bunch of
like 2016 ass arguments about like well
you interview gang members and you ask
them about being in gangs and so
therefore that's bad like you're making
them gets in trouble and it's just like
bro we've come too far as a internet
Community to think that people are going
to be fooled by these boring ass
arguments like yeah just just stop yeah
yeah it's very true what do you what do
you uh like you keep you're one of those
guys who probably keeps thinking about
different ways to kind of stay
entertaining and and things to talk
about which is kind of weird right does
it always surprise you that you can
always find something to say and
something to do every time you do a
podcast yeah I mean it's weird cuz I
interview so many goddamn people I I
interview like an average of about two
or three people per day so I'm just like
grinding out these insanely long
sessions of of talking to people but
yeah I mean that that that [__] comes
easy to me what gets a little bit more
difficult is when you have to sit on
camera and just talk about nothing like
I could interview somebody every day for
the rest of my life and that's just the
easiest thing in the world to me but
when you have to really start like
digging for for Clips or news articles
of [__] to talk about sometimes I find
that [__] kind of demotivating yeah no
[__] is is there are you at a point
where the stuff with the plug talk is
there a number in your head where like
if we hit this we're going to stop I
think that you can only do it for so
long I feel like we kind of already are
at the point where we could probably
just like stop if we wanted to but for
me and her I mean we're both just still
kind of having fun with it and but you
could still do it not film it like not
create such a a spectacle around it that
feels like such a waste not filming it
cuz it's like we [__] all these girls
back in the day and when I think about a
lot of them I'm like holy [__] [__] what
an L that we did not record that and put
it out because that would have been
[__] amazing content in some cases
like there there we did this one
threesome with her old roommate Emily
and she did a YouTube video about it
that got like 10 million views or some
[__] and we didn't record that threesome
and we recorded that through some it
probably over the last eight years would
worth like a million dollars to US and
I'm not at the point in my life that
that much generates that much it would
have sold on only fans over the years
even with being presumably relentlessly
bootlegged and everything as well it
still probably would have been worth
about that amount to us so in in
retrospect now it's like how much of a
sacrifice is it to set up a couple
cameras if if you're going to do
something on camera you know but because
you're doing like stuff that's against
Community rules on YouTube so your your
only fans is popping they can't control
that but do they still kind of Shadow
ban you like have you seen numbers on
your other shows go lower now Bren let's
take a little break can we take a break
from talking with little Adam 22 Yeah
I'm going to be in spaan this coming
week weekend then I'm off the hook
comedy club in Naples Florida great club
dude oh best car uh collection is in
Naples is that true I'm might pick
myself up a car I might get you
something wrap a bow around it you know
what I'm saying I don't think we can
afford the cars there but little too
expensive I know houses are $60 million
there well go to that car collection
well if you want to make money though
brenon if you want to make real money
you have a way where I can access more
car you diversify your portfolio dude
this is where gold Co comes in oh my God
like Scrooge McDuck talking about gold
coins have you ever had hey you want to
borrow gold in what time in history did
anybody go nah it's okay never yeah gold
it's gold and right now is the best time
to diversify your money and savings with
precious medals like gold and silver
gold code has helped thousands of people
place over 2.5 billion in gold and
silver they're rid a plus by the Better
Business Bureau they have five star
reviews oh my God they have so much
going on right now for the fireing kid
listeners they're offering you guys up
to $10,000 in bonus silver bonus silver
while supplies last all you got to do is
go to Gold code.com that's G code.com
fighter to learn more that's gold
code.com fighter it's all about
diversifying your
portfolio um tell me about what's going
on with this UFC 296 I'm excited you
should be excited cuz we have a fight
campaign I mean you're not on it you
being spoken but me I got Rampage I got
Rampage and Cheeto coming on rampage and
Cheeto is coming down for UFC 296 Going
Down live on
YouTube you can watch it and bet UFC
296b it's the best card of the Year UFC
is ending 2003 with a stellar card you
got Kobe com Leon Edwards got IM Machado
Gary vente luk you got shot Wonderboy
got Patty pinet Tony Fon which we
already have a bet on it but if you want
to bet smart do a draftking Sportsbook
right now use the code fighter new
customers get $150 instantly in bonus
bets for bet just $5 r on only at
draftking Sportsbook the official
Sportsman partner of the UFC the code
Fighter the crown is yours gambling
problem call 1800 Gambler or visit
w1800 gambler. net New York call
8778 heny or text hen4
67369 in Connecticut help us avelable F
problem gambling call
888878 9777 7 or visit ccpg dorg please
play responsibly on behalf of booill
casino and resorts in Kansas 21 plus age
varies by jurisdiction avoid an Ontario
bonus bets expire 168 hours after
issuance cdk ng.com MMA for eligibility
and deposit restrictions terms and
responsible gaming resources have you
seen numbers on your other shows go
lower now not really that reality show
we just like censored every [__]
swear word we we did everything we could
to keep it as YouTube safe as possible
and then we did four episodes and the
first three were all fully monetized and
then the last one was where these dudes
were doing like a strip te like lap
dance type thing competition on her and
we edited the [__] out of it because the
one dude who won l d he was like really
like grinding on her and like it it was
a little much from YouTube standards and
we were also judging their dicks like
they had to pull their dicks out and you
could see their [__] arms jerking off
in multiple situations and I've been on
YouTube long enough I was like no
masturbation no jiggling shoulder no arm
movement at all they cut all that out
and we still got age restricted on that
last
it just happens and it doesn't affect
your other stuff they're not like
translating over what's affecting your
other numbers I don't think so cuz like
I mean every day I'm posting clips from
YouTube from rapper interviews where
they're smoking weed and doing God knows
what big ass bottle of Hennessy on the
table so I feel like we probably have
already been placed in a section of
YouTube I remember like somebody posted
a bunch of uh data basically showing how
my content never got on the uh the
trending page or whatever and and a lot
of other channels too I think this is
back in the day when Rogan was still on
YouTube and like his stuff just would
not hit the trending page no matter how
well it was doing meanwhile all this
other [__] that was performing way worse
would hit crazy cuz YouTube Just they
they have an agenda they have their
favorites and then you get on a list and
you know it's no mystery we're on the
list we got on there and it's just it's
not that you can't still do well we do
fine but it will never like we'll have a
clip go viral but it will never be
trending like they'll make sure you
don't reach that level yeah all good
yeah what are you going to do is what it
is well what the what what's happening
is people are going to come up with
their own channels like you guys are
doing right so you can get it on on only
fans and what's the other thing you can
get it on uh well there's there's a
bunch of ones fans Le no I'm saying that
you you do you your podcast when you
when you interview female porn stars
plug talk plug talk the full unedited
versions on only fans and then we put
all the clips on Tik Tok and Instagram
and YouTube and everything like that to
kind of promote it but then the full
length versions on only fans and that's
the one called plug talk yeah and in the
other you do another podcast my rap SL
like internet culture podcast is called
no jumper and we got like almost 5
million subscribers on YouTube and we
kind of that that we still talk to porn
stars once in a while in there but it's
not really the Focus right yeah and then
your boy what's it KP ma m in the feds
he's in trouble yeah yeah he might have
got 10 years they're saying he's about
to soon just a hella gun charges as a
felon he was just holding guns as a
felon yeah I mean he's the kind of guy
like you know there's a very famous gang
in La called the Hoovers he has Hoover
killer tattooed on his forehead have you
never seen this guy Brian he's such a
Char put in perspective he such I love
how the AI the fake AI photos show up
before any a lot of the
other but he he looks crazy I know you
look at him say Jesus but there's he's
so likable there's something lovable
about him yeah he's you can tell he's
like a good person but he's so unique
the way he talks like Play a clip of him
talking so Brian can the way he had a a
ghost gun which I guess is like a very
very serious charge but I I only say
that he has that [__] tattoo on his
forehead to say that he realistically is
in more danger than most people so him
having a gun you know he because he's
yeah panel I'm not talking about
baseball or basketball what are you
talking
about shorty tweaking on
K yellow what so you're you're consumed
with your Ops today is that that's what
that's what's going on part of gang
banging right but you you seem like you
were like extra eager to bring up how
much you hate the other side there for a
second what other side are you talking I
don't know I mean you you tell me I
don't know who who you got issues
with he's a character what the [__] hey
he's a character I've never watched that
[__] back so it's
so shocking like who what was he going
through that day I mean he said he has
schizophrenia so I feel like that looks
a little bit like Tourette's yeah I
don't know exactly and he he's when it
comes to gang bang like he's about that
life like he's an actual gang banger
yeah he ain't [__] around yeah so
it's like you know he realistically has
very dangerous people that want to kill
him so he's moving around with guns
that's the whole trap that the justice
system gets you into is you catch a
felony you can never have a gun I mean
he's he's a a [__] he's just waiting
for it if you don't got a gun on him
realistically even him having a gun he's
in a lot of danger so but they put you
into that position where you can't
defend yourself and for him and do you
feel any danger being around associated
with him around him all the time no I
would say with him I've always the
platform kept a little bit of distance
you know where like I didn't want to be
necessarily like super involved with his
career to the point where the people
that he has problems with look at me as
like a representative correct of him so
I've always kind of like had him on the
show but at the same time I never wanted
to be like his manager even though I'm
sure that I could have helped him a lot
I mean he's a lot to deal with as a
person just cuz he has all like personal
issues like mental issues yeah he's just
just like I mean he's just out of his
[__] mind as a to manage him would be
a lot but now we're kind of I I heard
that the average amount of time that a
person gets from his charges is like
five years okay that's a long time which
is a long time but so are you going to
be sad if it goes away for five years I
mean five seems like it would be
optimistic at this point so five would
be a lot better than 10n if we go wait
for 10 it's like game overz how are you
I'm 40 he's 50 you still going to be
doing this [__] you know well I have a
lot of people tell me that if he goes
away for 5 or 10 years that they
strongly believe he will leave gang
banging behind and convert to being a
Muslim or or doing something more
positive that'd be good yeah Channel 5
News Andrew Callahan he did a recent
like deep dive into KP Max history and
interviewed his mom and everything and
I'm I'm sure he comes from a tragic
background or what uh yeah his uh dad
died when he was younger he walked his
mom found her ex-boyfriend having butt
sex being gay oh right yeah bunch of
crazy stuff and George said being gay
yeah he's not a big fan of of the
homosexual movement now we know yeah
wasn't he trying to fight someone over
was he trying to fight
you I've said a lot of gay [__] to him
and he quite often gets triggered to the
point of nearly wanting to attack me
yeah like riding that line you know I
love it I mean I I said something gay to
him the other day and he like kind of
like stood up in the podcast and was
like towering over me and I reached up
to like stop his arm and my thumb went
directly into his arm pit and then I
smelled it got really wet in there and
then I smelled it and it didn't actually
smell that bad cuz I think he's Samoan
so it's like is yeah he's kind of like
hairless and [__] he said he can't even
grow a beard he's hairless he's like a
hairless cat you know what you are
you're like the Howard Stern of like
this weird like rap porn world yeah but
Howard Howard chickened out at a certain
point and decided he need to go I'm I'm
never changing I'm doing [__] up [__]
the rest of my life for for you how that
where do that come from uh being really
really immature and never having to grow
up with the whole BMX thing like I spent
my whole 20s and my early 30s riding
bikes around in the city hanging out
with my friends hanging out with people
who on average were a lot younger than
me too you know like if that's one thing
in BMX is like you can get older the
average BMX rider is still going to be
like 18 so you never really grow up that
much when a lot of your influences and a
lot of the top people in the sport you
know MMA you could still be a goat at 35
or 40 but BMX it's like the the dopest
dudes are a lot of times like 18 to it's
like Tony Hawk was skateboarding he'd
hang out but it's it's like he's like
you know whatever he's 50 now everyone
he's hanging out was like 19 sport as
you get older so a lot of times the best
people are like pretty young so you
could be like a 40-year-old team manager
for a bmx brand and you're driving a van
around with a bunch of you know
20-year-old kids in the back ticktockers
and [__] yeah what do you think he' be
doing if you weren't doing this you just
kind of fell into it huh yeah I don't
know I've always pretty much everything
I've done has been like an iteration of
the same thing of like oh I'm excited
about this [__] so I'm going to make
content about it whether it's I'm going
to make I'm going to write blog posts
I'm going to make a YouTube video I'm
going to do a podcast so it's very hard
for me to imagine what life would be
like uh Beyond this but like the other
day I watched an interview on the nine
club which is this really great
skateboarding podcast and they were
talking to a guy who's like a a sports
uh agent or like manager for young
skateboarders and I was like oh yeah
like that's the kind of thing that I
could probably have to get into is like
managing Talent once people got sick of
seeing me on camera who knows how long
that'll take it probably probably could
happen at some point yeah I don't know
though it sounds like you're like I
always am fascinated with anybody that
can cut through the think about how many
podcasts and how many [__] people are
out there and some people somehow are
able to stay relevant that's really
difficult yeah and it keeps just getting
more and more cluttered and more and
more competitive you know it's pretty
wild I know especially now like do you
want to listen to like random dudes talk
about sports or do you want to watch
like these retired athletes who are
insane like world famous talk about
Famers yeah this is like totally foreign
to me cuz I don't know about sports like
that but like my friends have told me
like yeah the whole Sports Marketplace
has been changed because you know you
could be an analyst but a lot of these
people want to listen to Shaq they want
to listen or or they the Kelsey Brothers
like they're both one plays for the
Chiefs one plays for the Eagles breaking
down football or I can listen to Joe and
Billy who they happen to be fans listen
to two Hall of Famers what do you listen
to what podcast uh I listen to a fair
amount of political stuff yeah well the
fighter in the kid yeah and uh you know
some hip-hop stuff but I'm more in my my
clip era you listen to political stuff
yeah like what uh well my favorite
streamer is Destiny whose wife left him
for another man I love Destiny I
interviewed I did a podcast with him oh
did I just texted him I hit him up
saying I hope you're doing all right a
couple days ago he didn't respond to me
so [__] him stupid yeah probably going
through it yeah he's going wait his
name's Destiny yeah so D I love this guy
so Destiny he he's he's a liberal but
he's such an intelligent like he's such
an intelligent like guy on the left with
like he will how far left is look at
this [__] smoke show broke his heart
isn't she bad as [__] she's she's
beautiful he's like 10 years older than
her he's just so he's so smart he's so
fair he's such an interesting guy man
whated he gets in the belly of the Beast
like he came on a panel with a bunch of
like people who were like libertarian
and all that and he gave as good as he
got he was just he was right there yeah
and that's that's what I love about him
is that he'll gladly go on all these
sort of red pill podcasts and and de
debate people on the right whatever and
I feel like he's got a way better chance
of like bringing people to his side
because he's willing to sit down with
all these guys and argue with them you
know which a lot of people on the left
are just allergic to that [__] because
so many of their ideas aren't really uh
tested out in the real world so they
just look stupid as [__] as soon as they
start arguing exactly he he he'll sit
there literally with like a bunch of
people in the panel doesn't matter who
it is and like he is just a a background
in poly Sai or something I don't know
he's just so thoughtful we did a podcast
and and I I just I love getting people
on who I think I'm going to have
disagreements with or at least I'm going
to be able to push back and I I found
myself agreeing with way more than I
didn't because he's just so thoughtful
you know he just knows he knows what
he's talking about and spends the time
he's earned his point of view that's
cool but he's just a good guy too his
relationship was like the real life
version of what me and my girl do where
we're actually totally monogamous
besides a handful of scenes that we or
you know a lot in my case that we shoot
with other people on camera but he
actually had a relationship with that
girl we were looking at before where
they both had full license to have sex
with other people interesting and had a
totally open relationship and and he's
been smeared as a cuck by all kinds of
people on Twitter and everything
pointing out that uh you know his girl
is getting [__] by other guys and I've
heard him tell all kinds of stories
about [__] other girls and everything
like that but at a certain point I guess
she went back to Sweden where she's from
and there's this little twinky [__]
dork who uh she ended up [__] and
somehow she got roped in psychologically
all of a sudden they're connected and
now he's like leaving her because she
totally [__] him over that's the
danger zone though right exactly you
know what I mean like if the problem is
be in another country and you're going
to have a it's you're playing with
you're playing with fire it's just
because she left him he's a millionaire
he's pretty famous she left him for a
total random non-binary guy who
skateboards wearing a helmet so like
pretty much he got he got his [__] took
by like the lowest of the low I would je
like all right go ahead he SK that's the
cucking you that would that would hurt
my feelings yeah if that guy took your
girl no I'd rather I'd rather lose my
girl to that guy than than some [__]
like no if it's like Dennis Rodman or if
it's Adam you're like all right I can
see that but this guy like yeah dude a
non-binary his I at Subway and I took
your [__] girl and I ride a bike with
a helmet then I be like H I still got a
chance of getting her back or she's
going through a phase do you know what
I'm saying I don't know I don't know but
do you really want her back after bummer
the whole thing's a bum if she shows
that she's like possibly going to leave
you for a guy who does hippie hops in a
helmet at the skate park at a certain
point I know that doesn't mean a lot to
you guys but just like seeing him skate
and realizing that he had the gayest
style that I ever seen in my life I was
just like damn that it made it so much
worse that this dude took his [__] so I
really feel for the guy he was like a
big wave surf you're like all right I
think that's probably yeah CU back in
the day I had a ex-girlfriend leave me
for a guy who was like without question
much more successful than me and I'm
talking like 10 plus years ago get it
right but yeah but it [__] sucked cuz
I'm looking at him I'm like well I got
this amount of money in the bank [__]
this guy's probably a millionaire this
guy's on TV this like what the [__] like
I I got to just accept that she made a
good decision that hurt way worse that's
what I mean and it made you step your
game up though exactly I got depressed
as [__] for like a month and then I kind
of like emerged from that the fire with
the real passion of like I'm going to
show you [__] yeah see what it did you
have nowhere to go if the dude's just
some regular gay SK you make a good
point it's it's that that's that does
cause you to step your game up yeah hell
yeah there are guys I I I that's the
truth of being honest like there are
guys if your girl left you there are
some guys you'd be like I get it I mean
I yeah you
my I'm way older than my girl so if she
left me for like a a really successful
35-year-old I'd be like I mean I can't
blame you I'm very sad but all right you
know yeah that was like recently like
Drake followed my girl during all this
[__] okay problem and it's like it's a
weird feeling cuz it's like cuz if Drake
wants your girl it's like a vulture in a
tree it's like you better not do it but
be cool Drake I understand I get it why
you would do it but don't you
this is a hard cut offline I'm not I'm
divorcing your ass we're not together
I'mma take the kid I'mma tell the judge
that you [__] Drake [__] cuz if Drake's
going for your girl I mean do you know
what though you know what you got going
for you you're an original what you're
original you're Drake you piece of [__]
pretty original I'm saying that I'm
saying that that what's good about like
sometimes when you're doing your own
thing and you're pushing the envelope
like you are that takes a certain kind
of like original personality and I think
people I think woman like will look at a
guy like yourself and go I could go over
there but this is too much fun he don't
know who Drake is I know so all that
said I love you but if Drake slid in my
wife DM that's the one guy like he
doesn't have t he's got a thousand girls
though hold on I have a question then I
have two one so you do get
jealous I mean she never has really
given me a reason to be jealous besides
like doing the stuff on camera with
another guy which I get like temporarily
jealous but it's kind of hard to hold
hold on to it because our relationship
is so is there certain things where that
triggers you like while you're in the
the midst of tag team and your wife is
there certain things you're like all
right man take it easy no I I didn't
feel any kind of conflicted energy when
I was [__] her with this other guy
but when she did the first scene with
this guy Jason love where she actually
middle of the day on a Sunday went to a
hotel room with a filmer and shot the
scene with this other guy and I'm seeing
the footage and I'm seeing him eat a
[__] and all that and I'm just kind of
like ah okay like I I intellectualized
my way around this like I had accepted
that but then you actually see it and
you realize like look at how big he is
oh my
God yes that's a giant dick yeah that's
like the size of my forearm and that I
had like a moment or two of like God
damn and even if she were to like just
go shoot a scene with another guy right
now I probably feel a little conflicted
about it but at the end of the day it
doesn't really feel like that big a deal
good for you man are there rules like
are there certain things you guys can't
do is anything off limits yeah um well
the rules I told her when she went and
did the first scene with the guy was I
was like no kissing don't let them come
in your
mouth can it come anywhere else those
are rules I think those are the only
rules come anywhere else though just not
the mouth question uh he could yeah
besides that yeah he can bust in her in
the ass yeah I mean we're prepared for
that if they were going to do anal that
would have been a totally different
conversation see well see you didn't say
I want to know
she was like surprised we did anal today
I would have been oh my god get me out
of here but um yeah I mean whatever I I
just me and Lil de nutted on her face
together yeah all right all right yeah D
so take that take that take that Crowder
tell Crowder about that yeah tell your
boss about that say my boss tell your
boss said your boss I was like who the
[__] is I thought about Rogan cuz he
thinks I don't know he don't he thinks I
don't know anything I'm out here man
you're out here dude you know you did
all your research I've been doing
research for years yeah one of my I
loved remember Rogan like really got on
your ass cuz you're talking about like
how you beat everybody in the whole
world up yeah but I was making a joke
that's what they don't
realize got reminded and I were going to
I was going into a bit because I was
going yeah I'll [__] you up and he goes
oh this is where Brian thinks he's St I
go you you cut me off and I just saw
that and realized that was it no do you
remember that where I I was going to go
I was going I was about it was a long
time ago No 5 years ago more and I was
about to go like this I was about to go
yeah and and you know I was going to and
I'll tell you something else you you you
come at me you better come at me correct
I was going to joke around with you yeah
and he thought I was being tough so now
it says Joe Rogan straightens out Tough
Guy Brian K I saw that and I was like I
was like hey hey I was doing a bit but I
got stopped in the middle of it and it
sounds like I was trying to be tough
that does make way more sense cuz I
remember watching like one of these
little YouTube commentary videos talking
about it and I'm just thinking in my
head like what the [__] is Brian doing
like you're in a room full of [__]
MMA fighters and you're talking like
you're God and I was just like that is
weird like of course it's weird I would
never do that that does make a lot more
sense yeah I was literally about to go
into a bit and I didn't realize that
sometimes you will do that no no no I
would never do that cuz I was G to I was
literally about I was cutting you off
and I was going to I was saying
something about how I was going to beat
you up yeah which is hahaa that I was
going to go in and you would have picked
up on it but Joe Cuts me right off and I
and I saw that circulating and I watched
I go what and I was like oh no that was
circulating now or back then well it
just made the rounds where I was four
hours is never going to make the rounds
again it's just like oh look at this
five minutes we got right here though
this [__] is [__] CRA he started telling
me how that that I was around toxic
people and I was like oh jeez this is
this is I was was like I know I was like
I don't want I don't feel good right now
the baddest i' ever seen R get at you is
me and Brian were [__] around when he
had the studio up here and Brian we're
like literally [__] around and he
grabs a pool Cube you know Rogan loves
pool we don't know pool but he grabs
this Cube and it's [__] it's like a
$88,000 pool Cube but Brian's using it
like a [__] like sword at me and he's
about to break it and Rogan comes out of
the bathroom goes what the [__] are you
two doing no no cuz he goes he's like
what the [__] you put it down I looked
at him and I go I don't I just wanted to
[__] I like poking the bear and I go uh
it's rough how Sunday today and he goes
what I go it's rough house Sunday I feel
like rough housing around with and so he
goes so R goes he's dressed up he goes
nah I go nah come on and I start kind of
pushing him and he's like okay then I
push him again then I slap him in the
face and then he goes I I knew I was in
trouble cuz he took his watch
off he goes and I go no no he goes no
come on I go no no no and now he starts
chasing me around the pool table and I
grab a pool T queue and I'm trying to
keep him away but you he's using it like
a sword he's like it's a $6,000 P que we
didn't know was like what the [__] Fu it
was handmade he saw the video of us if
you were chasing me it was called rough
house Sunday and then you took me and
you squeezed me until I I almost peed
this is this is the video chin I is this
one ad do you remember this is it looks
like for a full year and it turned me
into a [__] if somebody tried to Bull
me I'll show you look so different you
look like the rock you're a little
serious there angry you're dead serious
there I hate not true bul you try bully
me right now [__] see what I'm
doing you've talked to too many guys at
left see he stopped me and then it
becomes like you know you were serious
to that first part like any like a
normal guy bulling you and then you were
going to do a bit with me and that and
Rogan jumped in the middle yeah I'm like
dude come on I was like about to go to
you and stuff you're about to go do a
bit yeah yeah and I would have gone on
about that but I'm not I'm not talking
about being a tough guy right I I I'm
never going to tell you a story you know
those guys who tell you stories about
high school when they were in sports or
the fight they got into oh my God and
you go I don't think this is true like
you know and while everybody exaggerates
we all exaggerate I'll exaggerate we
exaggerate but as far as like telling
like a I'm not going to tell you a story
I'm never going to tell you this story
if I got into a shoving match I'm not
going to say and then the dude swung on
me I ducked I came back and I I'm just
not going to go into that right that's a
lie just in general if somebody starts
telling you a long-winded story and then
at some point during the story you
realize that the whole purpose of this
story is just for them to tell you about
how tough they were one time or how they
punched someone or how they got over on
somebody it's just like oh what the [__]
like I am so much more economical with
my words like I'm just not going to tell
you a story where the end of the story
is like and then I [__] Three Chicks
yeah which like dudes do that to me all
the time and I realized partway through
like oh this is a terrible story and
they're doing it for them so you know
like hey dude I [__] yeah and especially
like telling me about you [__] Three
Chicks is like telling you about beating
somebody up it's like okay I've done
this for a living for all these years so
you really can't impress me by talking
about a bar fight you know sa your time
we deal with that all the time like
somebody I was an athlete Brennon goes
you're better about it now I'd have a
friend would be like I was I was a
really good athlete brenon goes what
what do you mean by that toine
that what mean where' you play no cuz in
high school I ran a four five as soon as
I here in high school no you didn't
though right you didn't four five is NFL
speed so we got to talk about this for a
second oh see there you go somebody
starts trying to wow you but you got
more knowledge okay I like that yeah
good that's awesome the worst I do I
knew there's dude back in the day who
would still like every six months he'd
post his high school football highlights
on his Instagram story you know and I'm
just like bro you're 26 like get over it
it's it's also four dude yeah what's
this four I love you could have made it
man like I ran Sprints with a bunch of
NFL players now I was 54 I and even when
I was 20 it would have been like I was
standing still and I was like I like
doing that just to see how tough I'm not
and how fast I'm not right and when you
run against those guys I I I think this
is not an exaggeration I could be at the
50 yard line and I think they would beat
me into the end zone absolutely right
what do you mean you think yeah yeah
like that's how much faster they are
where you just go but you knew that
though right you just want to be around
a buch I want to see it I want to feel
it but you want to be around a bunch of
black guys you know people joke around
there's like it's like a
real I know you guys are talking about
with track and field a room full of
kenyons around me lift lift more than me
right now so I can jerk off in the
corner and cry break that 5 minute
mile I like that you put yourself in the
belly of the Beast you know exactly
where you stand yeah most relationships
you know everybody dances around the
issues you guys are in the [__] you
got right into the trenches well you
know you want to know part of it is that
I know all these porn girls very close
and personally and I hear the [__] that
they say off camera so I've heard all
these girls like kind of complain about
how it's not so great [__] the 12in
gigantic [__] dick so from my
perspective it's less like I'm scared of
my girl getting pleasure from that and
more like damn all right like in pain
good luck good luck at work today I know
that shit's not going to be easy cuz
I've heard girls with way looser vaginas
than you talk about this [__] like it's
not so fun right so right 100% but
there's part of me that's kind of like
yeah we could we could do stuff with
other guys but I'm not really trying to
like push your vagina to the limits cuz
I'm trying to use this thing for the
next couple decades you got a race car
you don't want the I want I just want
content I don't want to I don't want to
kill the goose that lays was the drama
with homeboy who who who she did the
first scene with was that real where
you're like I know what you're doing
yeah cuz he was just kind of being a
knucklehead he's doing all these
interviews and he he probably didn't
realize when he shot the scene with her
that it was going to be that Viral all
of a sudden he's like famous on a
different level he's getting all this
attention and they're kind of B him into
talking [__] about me and I don't really
blame him for not necessarily knowing
how to manage those situations but
definitely that made us realize like oh
anybody that we're going to work with in
the future we need to really trust them
and we need to be willing to have the
conversation with them of like if if you
get asked about this this is what you
say you know because yeah it's too easy
to make a name for yourself especially
when we're just like way more famous
than like the vast majority of people
platform for we're an opportunity to get
clout that the average person in porn
isn't because we know hundreds of people
in porn who are in relationships and
they [__] each other's spouses and [__]
on camera and it's nothing and a lot of
people in porn are kind of like baffled
by the fact that the real world cares so
much about me and her having this out of
the box relationship because it's not
even slightly out of the ordinary in the
porn world you know por porn like has
become not only mainstream but such a
professional gig now right in a lot of
ways do do people stay in it for a short
period of time and then get out of it
for is the turn around really crazy A
lot of girls will have like a you know
20year porn career but they'll have
these long periods of time where they
get a boyfriend and they get out of the
game because girls always will meet a
guy and he he's attracted to them
because they're hot they're freaky they
make a lot of money they have a lot of
followers they have some degree of
status but then as the relationship
proceeds they get more and more you know
grossed out by the reality of their wife
going to work every day and [__] some
different dude so they kind of get out
of it I've seen this happened a million
times but then they always come back to
it at a certain point and they usually
regret missing out on a few years of you
know maintaining their relevance I know
so many girls who've like been in porn
and got out and been in and got out so
many times that the fans just kind of
dissipate and don't even it's hard to
make money though isn't it well not on
only fans I know so manys than because
you're you're taking out the it'd be
like if you're an actor and you didn't
have to deal with Hollywood like you
don't have to deal with Studios anymore
you just set up a camera you go on only
fans you're not giv a huge percentage to
whatever is pornhub or whatever braz
brazers or whatever you can just do your
own thing now yeah whatever browers yeah
browsers browers browsers browers well
that's the
fancy yeah it cost extra dude it's only
black guys um yeah but so you don't need
the studios anymore you do it from your
living room and you don't have to give
this huge chunk of change anymore a lot
of girls making six figures a month and
then meanwhile if you go shoot a sign
for brazers they're going to give you
like 1,500 bucks like something I don't
see how they can keep up it it the girls
look at the mainstream porn companies as
basically like promotional opportunities
because it's like okay if you're getting
posted a bunch of times by brazers vixon
they've got millions of followers
they've got a huge [__] audience of
hardcore porn fans so you're going to
get a bunch of fans and a bunch of
followers by doing content for them but
ultimately at the end of the day most of
the girls are still kind of focused on
bringing people back to there yeah who
do you think is the hottest porn star
Jesus probably Lena the plug my wife
wife great answer gotcha come on a
shitload of hot ones outside your [__]
uh Savannah Savannah Bond she kind of
comes to mind she bring her up she got
the biggest she's blonde she's
Australian she got the biggest boobs and
the biggest ass you ever seen in your
life she how do you spell her last name
uh b o n d all natural bond not natural
not not at all but she's she's doing her
thing uh she comes to mine I'm not
familiar with her work click on one of
the blurry ones for
me well there go okay well she got a I
haven't [__] her in the butt but she
got a hell of a butthole on her because
she always doing anal she's very pretty
yeah she's cool yeah she's very pretty
but there's a lot well I mean oh another
one you might not know about this but
you ever heard of Sky Bri Sky Bri Sky
Bri is pretty much like the biggest new
porn star to emerge over the last few
years and she um she I met her when she
had about 4,000 followers oh she's super
pretty I've SE her
stupid Jes and I told I told my girl and
this is right after my girl had the baby
and I told her I'm like listen I met
this girl we need to manage her we need
to sign her up she's she's it she's
she's got like a perfect body beautiful
face really nice natural tits whatever
and so my girl accepted we signed her
she blew the [__] up she's like by far
one of the biggest girls on only fans we
managed her for like 2 years she got so
big during the process of that that you
know she she ended up believe in the
management situation and she stopped
doing porn as well she's just like just
just post cute photos of herself as well
as like she's got you know her her bank
of content that she's done with other
guys and stuff over the years but she's
good yeah and me me and my girl I
brought my girl that deal and we both
made millions of dollars off of Just
signing this one girl which is [__]
trippy because she set now she yeah she
she makes many many hundreds of
thousands dollars a month so just she
can do whatever the [__] yeah I've seen
her before she's she got a boyfriend now
she's chilling she's not even shooting
porn anymore good for her I mean bummer
for me good for
her she's beautiful that's insane but
that was tough to go to my girl who had
just had the baby she's feeling like a
[__] cow she's like you know walking
around feeling like [__] she cuz she has
C-section baby pulled up out of her
she's not sleeping whatever and I still
had to go to her and be like listen like
we have to do this I found the
22-year-old girl or whatever in my my
you have to do what though you have to
sign her yeah like I had to convince my
girl like this is not commentary on your
body or or how you look right now this
is just purely a business decision oh
and also we're going to [__] her a bunch
of times on camera to get the ball
rolling she she quit Target to sign with
us no [__] yeah in Pennsylvania rural
Pennsylvania Target's the spot man I
always say that yeah yeah I've been
Target a lot seen anybody her how did
she get into the business me through him
man the goddamn story she was a fan she
was dming me and just want trying to
tell me that she wanted to shoot with me
and my girl and I'm looking at her
pictures and I'm like this girl is she's
too hot like what is this like why do
you have 4,000 followers you're way too
hot to have 4,000 followers and you want
to do porn and you know we just that is
unreal now she has a she was just
hitting you and she's like I want to do
porn she's at Target she's impossibly
beautiful like that's crazy that photo
is quite photoshopped but I'll also say
she does look very very good un
photoshopped yeah yeah yeah that that's
amazing and so she just blew up cuz she
you found her and you guys did that and
that was the end of that there there's
her with a nut on her face yeah look at
that from Target to that from Target to
facials getting deals but uh yeah that
was pretty much it and uh yeah I mean
but it was just so you know a lot of
people were like thinking that we're
were going to be butt hurt over her like
not being managed by us after the two
years was done but it's like bro she she
all of a sudden was on ksi's channel and
she's dating Jake Paul at a certain
point and she's just doing every single
thing you could possibly imagine doing
with like celebrities just being an
influencer yeah it's like at a certain
point it's like what am I going to like
I mean she served out the contract for
two years she did her yeah she if we
wanted we could ass signed her to a
really oppressive fiveyear contract and
taking 50% of her money and [__] you
know owned her Instagram that's what a
lot of these only fans managers do so
it's like you want to leave okay boom
we're taking the the Instagram and then
we're going to change the Instagram to
have a different name and we're going to
give it to another girl that were going
to manage that's what they do we didn't
we we didn't want cuz that [__]
ultimately I think is going to leave
girl you're just a good businessman I
just for her for us with her she's like
a super sweet nice girl trying to get
into the game like I don't want to
manage her and then leave a terrible
taste in her mouth and have her go tell
other girls yeah don't work with them
have you had have you managed other
girls we managed yeah like a handful of
girls but I mean some of them just
didn't really necessarily have the the
we we still have some girls we they
don't have the it factor I mean it's
just so so hard to predict cuz after her
cuz she was the first girl we ever
signed after her I'm thinking oh we we
have a superpower now we could do this
to any girl it's not that easy but I
mean we certainly can like help any girl
but yeah I mean her her situation was
just a total outlier
unicorn all right what do you got for us
Jen I love it oh all right first thing
is uh the show hillani signing with the
Dodgers yeah that's for $700 million
deal over 10 years I think it is 10
years yeah and they don't even know if
his elbow's going to be able to p again
well he had Tommy Tommy John surge is
his second one I think it's a good
investment they're smart they're way
smarter than I am but they'll make 700
mil just off merchandise through 10
years just the merchandise think about
how stacked the Dodgers are now it's
insane it's stupid so he's the best
pitcher and best hitter in the game he
makes Babe Ruth look like [__] so crazy
yeah nuts really nuts it's so crazy wow
they're going to take Mike Trout next a
he's my that's that's my guy like ameran
what's crazy with with him is uh he's on
record like three years ago he did an
interview was like cuz he it's been
known he's going to leave the Angels
because it's a bad market so there was a
you know they're ask him about where he
wants to go he goes I would never go to
the Dodgers he doesn't like the Dodgers
don't like what they represent but 700
million he's like I like the Dodgers
yeah we all like the Dodgers and that's
guarant in baseball I don't know if you
guys noce that's guaranteed money so
whether he his elbow blew out he's paid
700 million no matter what wow like the
the Mets are still paying Bobby Bonilla
for still paying him 29 guarante
contract yeah 29 years old it's the most
money ever right for any athlete Sports
athlet it's almost double what LeBron
got for the in
his I think they thought he was going to
be the first billionaire athlete first
billion dollar contract wow with all the
other endorsements and [__] he'll
probably get there pretty quick huh oh
yeah he's a billionaire yeah CU he's ma
massive like massive already wow he won
the World Series like the the legit
World Series like Japan beat you USA he
hit the game with N Run he he's a
monster and just a clutch player and
everything else good at everything yeah
cuz a lot of times when guys like this
sign huge Deals they tend to not do as
well right that depends yeah he's been
making money for a while but God 6'4
Japanese dude so this is making the
rounds recently too Brock Les's daughter
I thought this was photoshopped no my
brother said to me like dude what the
[__] are you doing no sir this makes me
scared of how my kid's going to look one
day she going to look exactly [__]
like me that's I just had a daughter
hopefully she doesn't you know look like
me so anyways the daughter broke the
shoper record at her at Colorado State
you're [__] right she did strong you
got to see you got to see the the I
watched the video of her shot put and
she's got power and speed she looks
ready to knock Frank Miro next take a
look at her speed it's not dude she's
her dad with a wig of course she [__]
tossed that I think was at the bottom
Ser watch
this well I can't play
that but people don't realize how big of
a
freak oh my God people don't realize how
big of a freak Brock Lesnar is oh yeah
like granted he did PDS stuff like that
but outside that complete freak he was
that way in high school you ever see
pictures of him in high school freak I
got into youc because of Brock Lesnar
really I had never watched it and then
like 2008 I just saw like a commercial
on TV and was just like oh my God who is
this [__] freak like I remembered him
a little bit from seeing him in
wrestling and then I actually just F he
started watching UFC like every [__]
time he doesn't get enough credit for
what he did didn't have much experience
they tossed him the [__] wolves like
Keith hering was his first fight he's
fighting Frank Mayer then he's knocking
Randy Couture out then he's beating
Shane Carwin then Cain Velasquez alar
overing like Savage and remember in
wrestling he never played football went
from wrestling at uh University of
Minnesota monster straight to football
never played football try out for the
Vikings played as many games as I did
for the Vikings but still he was in
training Camp he's freak yeah I wonder
if she's ever been viral before this I
don't think so the first time we saw her
there must be a really weird experience
for her to be like on every [__] meme
page and sports site for looking exactly
like you my house of a father you know
where my house my my head went with this
is when I saw it cuz obviously you know
she looks like her dad I'm like oh the
internet's going to be mean to her
that's right my head I want that poor
girl internet's going to be so mean to
her you have kids that's yeah right away
I was like ah this poor girl but she's
awesome and look love it keep winning
Young Queen I don't know how much he's
put her out there but yeah I mean hold
on can we go back B goes keep winning
Queen why why yall talking crazy about
someone daughter y family member y'all
corny on social media but who's you're
assuming that's a black person shooter
who is that I know who it is I forget
but anyway either way say keep winning
young queen that makes me feel I didn't
I read that you [__] oh yeah this guy
Chris Matthews NBA shooting coach he
yeah people are going to be pretty mean
to her yeah when when I saw I'm like Ah
that's unfortunate she does she didn't
want to go viral she's doing her thing
in Fort Collins Colorado her dad's Brock
Lesnar he probably told her it comes
with the territory it's just going to
come yeah that doesn't help yeah well it
does if you don't listen to it don't
listen to it okay yeah yeah cuz you're
56 and that's so easy imagine me she's
17 you can do it you can do it 17 tough
man it's tough but you know U might be
18 you know whoever you are that you
know if people are saying shitty things
about you you're probably doing a good
job
yeah it's got to be hard to get that
into the mind of a of a kid though
because I feel like you know it's so
common now to just put your kid out
there on social media all the time and I
would assume Brock Lesnar hasn't really
but they' grown up in it and they know
this so my daughter at 15 you can have a
conversation with it she's very aware of
how toxic places like this are she know
there her friends are very aware of that
so what happens as these kids grow up in
it they grow up and and they're very
aware of when it starts and how to keep
it away I'm telling you it also depend
well but the difference is your
daughter's not famous you're not Brock
Lesnar like you're talking about
complete you're talking world famous you
probably had to tell her like hey you
might find a YouTube video that says
this this and this about me oh yeah you
got to have the social media
intelligence to not just take this as
gospel R into she did and she seen him
and she did so did my son and it's like
you know uh like you don't post your kid
right we did up until the whole [__]
went viral with uh you know her [__]
another dude and that just completely
like the the level of scrutiny that we
started getting about our family and
stuff just really made me feel like
let's let's just pull back let's just
not share this part I'm I don't post my
daughter my it's weird it might be
sexist my my sons I'll post they're good
they're Savages they'll beat up any it
doesn't matter doesn't matter never to
post doesn't matter it's three days old
you people post pictures of their new
newborn that's the first thing they post
I'm not post my dog you never posted the
newborn photo cuz I feel like I would
kind of be willing to post the newborn
photo if I hav another kid but I feel
like I would just have it be a oneandone
yeah I'm not I'm not posting the girl
the internet's too mean to to girls cuz
when you get bigger you just start to
really value your privacy yeah it's like
if I can have this be private in my life
I'm going to save myself a lot of
[__] headaches and you know it's like
if I post a really great photo of me and
my kid on Instagram yeah I'm going to
get a bunch of positive reinforcement
from people I know but I'm also going to
have to go and block like 500 [__]
people that leave terrible comments on
my [__] and I just don't well kids
people like I've even had that like with
kids you it's got to be a dicey
territory for you because you're
bringing a kid in the world exactly if I
was any other type of celebity whatever
but now that the porn thing kind of like
outshines everything else in my life it
just feels likey decision it's weird too
cuz like my kid talks about no jumper
all the time say talks about no jumper
but then doesn't even know the name of
the other [__] and like she goes to my
the no jumper store and like hangs out
with me and and she'll be at the office
and [__] like that but then meanwhile
obviously she's not invited to work when
there's anything plug talk related and
we we'll keep that going as long as we
can and then at some point have to have
the awkward conversation but I also feel
like the world's a lot more scar for for
women you know what I'm saying like I
that's why I don't want to post my
daughter like they just have different
words it's just critical too it's just
like there also a lot more creeps a lot
more pedophiles like when it comes to
little girls I just don't have no desire
boys too but I think I think that good
luck mest my kid let me know how it goes
for you [__] I think at the end of the
day it's just also like like like like
how critical people are on somebody's
looks you know for a girl [__] it's
hard oh yeah that's why it's tough for
her Brock Lesnar could have an ugly ass
son and it's not viral nobody cares but
this girl just looking like him is the
most viral [__] thing of last week
you know and it's it's like right when I
saw I'm like a that poor girl I respect
him doing as much as he can to hide her
away and not make her have to deal with
that there's probably a huge percentage
of people that she went to school with
that didn't even know she was his his
daughter until this right so it's
probably been quite there more pictures
of her that that might that's also kind
of a straight on picture where there's
no eyebrows cuz what if there's other
photos where it doesn't look that crazy
yeah you know what I mean like that's
kind of and Brock Brock Lesnar Brock
Lesnar is a sweetheart too like such a
nice guy the one time my buddy who was
in his Camp he said the one time I saw
him snap is when he was holding his
daughter this guy asked for a picture
and he's like give me a second man he
grabbed his arm but he's holding his
daughter he's like that's the only time
I saw him snap she is built she is just
you know life's tough man
strong strong G I mean look at that one
on the bottom left like here if that's
her she doesn't really look like them
that much there it's like a similar
photo where they don't look that similar
you know yeah there you go that's it all
depends on the angle yeah I don't have a
bad angle and she's a superstar
athletically so should be all right he
got a neck like a [__] wilderbeast
dude yeah oh that's his son oh that's
his son damn that's kid a stud yeah yeah
maybe pause but he looks great yeah yeah
there you go and and is are these kids
all with Sable from WWE I that was my
jam I used to jack it hard to Sable dude
D I remember her let me see sa she's
like the first WWE Diva she's my f I
love those div Divas in general mhm oh
yeah type in WWE Sable Sable she was so
pretty super wow look at her you
remember Miss Elizabeth damn yeah she
was my favorite that was uh Macho Man
Randy Savage's babe damn Sable was fly
as [__] yeah yeah she was she was
gorgeous go the one where she's in the
in the on the beach Jen remember China's
[__] yep I don't yep look like a dick
[__] was huge pinky finger yep that
China documentary is
sad she's she's yeah she was cool back
in the day yeah so I wonder if that's uh
the girl's Mom oh look at that she got
some hands which one's blurred out go to
that whoa whoa that would have had me
rock hard as a teager mhm God she is
just a stud stud these are the good old
days you're IND and that's Brock
Lesnar's woman man I don't know if
they're still
together the Brock he have kids with
that yeah that's his wife oh okay that's
his wife that's why I brought her up
dude oh I'm sorry that's his wife there
you go I think her mom might be Sable or
I know the son's okay Sables kid right
that's pretty AES all right to put a
ribbon on this there's someone that
pointed this out so Brock Lesnar
obviously fought Frank Mir in UFC two
times and bamir is like this crazy MMA
girl right now in wrestling and Brock
Lesnar's daughter is obviously shot put
record hold or whatever so if they were
to ever it it it would be fun to see
them compete against each other but
obviously she's not in MMA W it's silly
cuz she doesn't wrestle it's just come
on dude Frank both their daughters are
killers is what I'm saying well one does
shot but the other's actually doing MMA
like she's a beast Frank's daughter's
such a beast a record holder though
that's that's killer Sable's not her mom
no a but the son is I mean yeah Frank
M's daughter's a freak is she super
beast Sable's not the parent of either
kid okay well it's not a fun story then
sorry what don't you get I want to see
the daughter that came out looking like
Sable yeah not the one that came out
looking like Brock
Lesman uh this one uh so Elon Musk has
come forward and said no matter what
happens in 2024 if the FBI wants to try
and censor him he's willing to go to
jail wow what could they put him to jail
for though putting up information they
fake news re he reinstated Alex Jones
what's the right thing to do yeah which
you know because you with with Elon
you're always trying to figure out are
you actually a principal Free Speech guy
or are you just kind of doing whatever
you feel like in the moment and with him
like he's already had more advertisers
fall out over the past couple weeks than
he he's had so far in this whole this
whole time running Twitter yeah because
he lost a shillo to people after he
posted a supposed anti-semitic
conspiracy theory or whatever acting
something about the Jews wanting to
replace white people in this country so
that they'll you know the great
replacement Theory or some [__] like
that and then I mean him reinstating
Alex Jones is probably like the number
one thing that he could do that will
cause further Advertiser
you know like they are out after that my
thing is does he care he's claiming that
he doesn't care he seems like he's like
coing the advertisers to leave him and
he thinks that they will be judged in
the long run by the American people that
the American people will be deeply upset
with Walt Disney and Coca-Cola and [__]
I don't really know that the American
people are going to see it that way I
they don't have that staying power the
American people forget and who are you
going to blame every Fortune 500 company
that pulls their you're going to blame
it on 400 different Brands like nobody's
going to do that people are going to
look at Elon and say oh you [__] it up
you you you lost but then also D Dana
White's doing the same thing Dan's doing
the exact same thing and business is a
booming yeah and Disney's not there's a
lot of people that that appreciate him
doing that that's for sure but U it
seems like a lot of the money is tied up
in in that influence of you were talking
about there are a lot of people like
Disney and Coke they but I think that's
how you make a change you don't bow down
to the just because they have dollars
and and they say don't do this otherwise
don't give money you have guys like Elon
Dan like [__] Y'all This Is What It
Takes if Twitter's basically going down
if they don't have all these massive
corporate
advertisers I mean what's what's the end
game here is he's just going to keep
starving the business of money because
it's not like he's got any other
brilliant uh you know techniques that
that are going to make them profitable
it seems like he's he's really got to
lean on The Advertiser thing and he's
he's just doing everything possible to
get the advertisers out of there or
maybe he doesn't care about advertising
has enough money to fund it himself and
he just wants freedom of speech and it's
not a business move for him he's spent a
lot of goddamn money to buy that thing
and he's got investors to answer to and
stuff that's really the shocking thing
is that they're seemingly still on board
with this at what point did does the
company get taken away from him or or or
does he kind of forced to sell it I
don't know cuz I I like Twitter the way
it is I like the fact that I could
scroll the feed every morning and see a
bunch of people getting murdered bunch
of porn whatever like I I love that it's
the only social media site where okay I
had a clip that was super viral of uh
one guy beating the dog [__] out of
another guy on my podcast and we
couldn't post it anywhere uncensored
besides Twitter was the only place if we
post on Instagram we're going to get a
strike if we post on YouTube we're going
to get a strike we had to post it on
Twitter it would be a sad day if Twitter
got to the point where you couldn't post
a fight or a bare set of tits because
you already know you can't post it on
every other social truth of what's
really going on you know what I mean
sometimes things are not politically
expedient and I'm sorry but YouTube will
will censor certain like if you have
certain guests in your podcast that
grade against the mainstream narrative
even if they're scientist or Psy I'm
curious how long YouTube's going to be
able to get away with that how long are
people going to put until they start
looking into YouTube you have
psychologist say who's uh who's been
studying psychology for 40 years and and
and has looked at what the trans
movement is doing to these kids or
exposes like don't get us demonetized
pushing this [__] if you look at what it
does to expose like say certain hospital
when kid comes in with different
comorbidities and they're like and they
they immediately give them puberty
blockers YouTube will censor you for
that you you you have that person on
even if they're just telling you what it
is you'll get you'll get censored but is
that still the case cuz I feel like a
lot of the social media companies have
kind of fell back on trying to combat
misinformation which like you know 2020
era was really out of control but okay
like threads seems interesting to me at
least from a marketing perspective
because I realized there's a pretty big
audience on there but I'm hearing all
kinds of journalists and stuff saying
that the the stuff that they would post
on Twitter about politics about what's
going on in the news is getting their
accounts blacklisted on threads which is
you know Instagram's Twitter copy think
who runs thread yeah so it's kind of Mak
me feel like do I even want to test
going onto this platform because if I
get my main Instagram account deleted
because I'm running a threads thing and
posting [__] on there as well because I
assume that porn related stuff will
probably be in the same category where I
don't want to lose my
uh yeah you can post whatever por you
want on next which is pretty crazy
because you could just like the App
Store like there's no only fans app
because it's too porn related which is
very strange because you have to pay
money to see naked people on only fans
whereas on Twitter all you got to do is
log in and there's [__] it's like every
porn star's favorite social media app is
is Twitter even though they do also feel
like they're Shadow band on there and
everything but you can post porn on
there you can link to your only fans you
can do all this stuff that on uh
Facebook or Instagram is going to get
you gone you
know what else you got Jen you watch
sports not really you know Sports gu no
here we go this is a good one so this is
Spain's hottest model but it's not a
real person it's an AI and the creator
of this AI says they generate around
€9,000 a month just off of this model's
picture pain for a fake girl though but
look at her but it it's so strange this
is fake you see her naked and all that
is that what it is she there's plenty of
photos pay to have her do whatever she
you want scolling there's like her and
bikini I don't have that thing I'll just
go to Instagram I see I see this in your
this is not a real person there's a dude
that just made wow so weird but he's the
one controlling the DMS and stuff
exactly this is where I start thinking
we're living in a simulation anyway it's
scary right yeah I don't know I don't
think I would jerk off to this
but I don't know I mean it's only a
matter of time till the quality of this
gets a lot better you can't tell yeah
the first sex doll that I ever you know
touched didn't seem too impressive but
I've seen one in the last year or two
that I was like oh wow if I had this in
my house I would totally bang this sex
doll I wonder if she gets
hate well she doesn't have feelings well
she's not real I know but it's still the
troll are like uh mid it's just like an
art project at a certain point but is it
all AI or do they go in and you know
sort of soup it up and and make it look
a little bit cuz I've seen a lot of AI
chicks that the hands are all [__] up
and really yeah the fingers look super
weird like the AI isn't capable of doing
the hands
correctly so interesting man you know
they have uh godamn you know you know
what they're doing some companies have
Rogan selling my friend's dad bought a
sleep apnea machine he fell for it yeah
because he's like Rogan was swears by
this but it was a [__] AI I text
Rogan I go you know that the people are
selling [__] he goes yeah there's not
not much I can do I like using your so
they they use Ai and they have Joo this
thing is great I use this all time so it
sounds like him cuz just they chop up
his voice they chop up his voice and all
that and so my buddy's dad bought a
sleep ABA machine spent a lot of money
like you go it's like dude you know I
mean it really should just be on
Facebook and Instagram whoever is
allowing them to run these [__] ads
you know I think they already have
policies against that but they It's
probably hard to enforce at a certain
point right Mr Beast is like so many ads
online Mr Beast trying to give you money
or get you to buy something and it's all
fake it's all fake oh yeah oh wow same
exact thing as the Rogan thing anybody
that they have like a large Bank of them
talking so that they could create the AI
from cuz Rogan's the perfect one they
got hours 50,000 hours guys making money
doing it too smart they'll figure it out
though to put a stop to did he actually
get the Sleep AP machine yes well that's
that's kind of I got I don't know if he
actually yeah did they send him the
product usually was selling the product
okay well what not terrible did he like
it he's like it's actually the best I've
ever had my buddy's like dad cuz a lot
of the people they'll scam You by
getting the money out of you like that
and then not even 100% profit margins
got be pretty nice pretty damn nice yeah
what else you got Jen all right the
computer's getting a little slow here
but let me see if this
is TS you have open I know but this
computer still is used to be really
strong I get anxiety looking at that
many
this is Alabama cop woman
cop oh yeah you see this yeah check her
out I don't have to say anything right
there in front of the
car I like her tough voice say what
again oh
yeah open oh my God okay okay okay oh my
oh my God
oh she's like
pinky say it
again bit oh
my takes no [__] man he had a gun why
she talk like that had a gun on cuz
she's from Alabama why is she just
giving him a little bit of the taser
like and that's not how this is supposed
to go now is she in big trouble here uh
she's suspended for now hold on he so he
was arrested for a trafficking fentanyl
what isn't good but he also had a gun on
him that's not
good I just mostly I didn't see the gun
part of them my problem no that's a
phone isn't it or no I think that's a
gun where's a gun she took that gun off
on the oh I see I mean my main problem
with her is just her disposition and her
weird fake tough voice like I feel like
the problem here is not police the
problem is female police
like I'm just not feeling her Vibes if
imagine you were a [__] cop on the
same Squad as her and this is out there
imagine how embarrassed you would be
true that this is what's happened to
your profession she said you want to
again shut your [__] ass up this is
wokness goingon toai right here man yeah
tell Crowder it just says drug related
charges tell my boss I got I want to
talk to him about this tell my boss your
boss so funny dude I was like
I didn't know you were going to think
that that was funny I I'm glad that
worked out good dud glad that worked out
I I didn't know he went bad on you I'm
going to tell him how cool you
are yeah is that it J for computer dies
yeah Mr Adam 22 dude it was great thank
you brother yeah I appreciate you guys
thank you for taking a break from your
nine podcast love to yeah
[__] let's do it we could talk about
Japanese baseball pictures and
[__] I feel like we talk about anything
I wouldn't have known you know I
interviewed people from different walks
of life that's Zion Williamson yeah I
interviewed Michael Rapaport in like
2018 and he told me about him and then I
got to like kind of experience it on a
higher level when he got caught up for
[__] this porn star and G that kind
of went away a little bit right he kind
of because he's balling now but he's
still he has a discipline issue he loves
to eat fast food really so the Pelicans
like kind of chubby huh yeah and he's
he's such a baller and the Pelicans like
bro we want to put you on a diet no more
fast food and he's like you got it and
then the next day some dude takes a
picture and he's at KFC he's like look
who I ran into he's like or like a 10
piece that's [__] up that you're worth
like $100 million and you just can't eat
the only food that you want to eat right
but if you're the Pelican it's like dude
we gave you 200 milk could you not eat
Taco Bell every day yeah and he's like
nah man I got I'm scoring he's so good
but he could be so much better if he
just get his [__] together cuz I have
such a motivating reason to not be a fat
ass and like which is the porn thing
it's like oh you got to be naked on
camera all these other guys are in
better shape than you you should try to
get in better shape can't have a gut but
then meanwhile it's like when I get done
a long day of [__] interviewing
people for eight hours straight what do
I want I want a [__] candy bar
and it's just like I I have a really
hard time not gratifying by drink are
you a drinker I smoke weed though about
to smoke a spliff on the on the drive
back to my neck of the woods there you
go well go it's uh plug talk on only
fans only plug talk.com $5 a month you
can watch like a 100 plus scenes of me
and my my wife [__] other women
together that's a listen five bucks
sounds like solid deal deal skip skip
Starbucks for a day and you go watch
Adam get his dick suck for God's sake
let's go support other girls who need
help with their
rent you know what I mean well we
appreciate it brother thanks for coming
on appreciate you guys for Real come
back anytime that was great